you know the stuffing the chicken that
is the better version of Thanksgiving
though news flash Asians eat chicken too
[Laughter]
[Music]
all right we got a little bit of news
from our friend Uncle Roger Uncle Roger
Roger so um he he got a little bit of
heat from particularly some certain
groups of people for something he said
about what kinds of people food
well what's new exactly he's always
saying funny controversial [__] listen
to this right here and this is you know
this happened a little while ago but I
just want to see what you guys think of
it okay Southeast Asian country called
good food you know yeah with the one
fruit from Laos but I love loves
countries yeah don't talk [__] don't
talk [__] like [__] version of Thai food
I know I don't look it but I am that
line
version
why are you laughing let's start with
you let's start with Chuckles over there
because uh he even already [__] put
us this gets canceled suit like you
already know there's some things you
just don't say dude like why would you
say that's just literally an uh not
classy disc but it's funny because of
how unclassy it is but isn't it I
thought the joke is because he Uncle
Roger like his character is a old Asian
Uncle yeah and a lot of old Asian uncles
have stupid racist beliefs right so he's
making up yeah that's the joke the joke
is that's what we would hear from a
person like this yeah and they'll
believe it yeah they'll be like oh
everybody knows that you know Thai
food's the best yeah it'll say something
stupid like everybody knows that
Filipino food is just copying Mexican
exactly yeah it's like what Steve says
about Filipino food that he loads his
plate up it just puts it in the [__]
trash
you're like that's a joke well this guy
says on with that you're like oh that's
but also I'm Steve's audience yeah this
is reaching people that they're not his
audience they just want to be but to be
fair Uncle Roger shits on pretty much
everybody though everyone gets it he
shits on the whites he he has so many
videos of him just watching white people
cook
and he destroys them yeah dude he
destroyed because to be fair though the
way they make some fried rice it's like
what the [__] are you doing what is
there like food preference for white
people you know how black people you got
like chicken Asian people you die we
were going on every food I'm gonna say
is gonna not gonna be your typical like
hamburger hot dog yeah you like
casserole I feel like the only thing
[Laughter]
meatloaf tableside oh we love table
sides
apple pie fruit salad yeah
you know what's crazy is everything that
you just named I'm like that sounds
disgusting yeah you're like meh tarragon
chicken salad Boston Market Boston
Market when I think of white people food
I think of Thanksgiving yeah yams see I
don't know how
you know the stuffing the chicken that
is the better version of Thanksgiving
though news flash Asians eat chicken too
but is it deep fried
technically Koreans got really good
fried chicken every all Asians got their
own version of fried chicken though and
we stole it from black people and that's
okay right but I think Fried Chicken in
general is just like it's it's worldwide
dude everyone's got their own chicken
dish you know I mean every country
different kinds of fried chicken except
white people yeah white people don't
even know how to fry well well actually
the Colonel Sanders as well Colonel
Sanders yeah or Cajun white they're
spicy whites Cajun white interesting you
look did you like
so
um it's fair to say a whole lot of La
ocean people were pissed about this I
think it's touchy because there's that
whole Thai Laos like what do you call it
um rivalry and their food is similar but
they want to differentiate themselves
like all the countries that are really
similar they probably are the biggest
like Rivals and then they don't like to
be like we're not like anything like
them you know it seems like it would be
difficult to to try to um like if you
had a la Ocean Restaurant out here and
someone's like oh what's the food like
you don't want to say it's like Thai
food you don't want to say that but a
lot of laotians open up Thai restaurants
though because people don't know what
love ocean food is I've never had a low
ocean food before it's simpler to Thai
food it's similar it's good yeah yeah
that's an example but when I had low
ocean food I had it in Nashville and
there's a huge lotion uh community in
Nashville and those dudes are they got
country accents and everything but
they're it's so like country infused
that it's probably not even like what
laution food traditional so it was a
typical meal I honestly don't know the
names it's just a bunch of meats that
were really good I don't I can't even
compare it so the I guess closest
comparison would be Thai food yeah yeah
like that's don't say that I know but
don't say that yeah that's what it would
be though but you guys are all saying
but they're not I don't think it's bad
to compare it and say that it's like
typhoon top 10 loud dishes you must try
Okay popular food sticky rice is a
staple throughout the country minced
meat salad AKA larb okay
salad
uh Steve fish baguette Pate wet noodles
crispy rice salad Lao sausages hold on
did these start in Lowe's and then
Southeast Asian dude right it's like
they're the same so they speak the
languages are similar right the only
reason why there's two borders is
because of the French there's no yeah
tell them
don't tell them that but they were a
kingdom of Champa don't tell them
it was the kingdom of Champa I think it
was the the or the Siam area it's they
were all like very I mean dude borders
are man-made right so like it's it's
kind of like people will be like oh
Japanese and Korean food is so different
and I'm all like nah dude Korean food is
like Japanese food but with more flavor
with sesame oil and kimchi it's like the
same ingredients yeah yeah
this is again according to Google food
from Thailand is typically uh or has
typically more curry has a heavier base
of Curry and much richer in flavor due
to the coconut milk base and much of its
cuisine loud food uses more lime and
tends to lean on the saltier side and
makes heavy use of padek which is made
of fermented freshwater fish oh that's
probably like the hawk the Chinese I
mean the Cambodian one you know what was
a trip when I first tried a lot of
Cambodian food because it looks like
Vietnamese food yeah so you have an
imagination of what it's gonna taste
like because if you if you if you tried
Vietnamese food first
that's what's in your head but then you
eat it and you're like oh what the heck
this is not what I thought it would
taste like but all of that area I don't
think it's mainstream I think that's the
thing is like the southeast Asia area
people only know Vietnamese and Vietnam
Thai they don't know anything else yeah
Thai food's so popular here it's kind of
a go-to to compare lots of Asian food to
Thai food because that's what you eat a
lot of you know why there's a lot of
Thai restaurants too it's um a lot of it
is government sponsored so the Thai
government that's their uh tourism
marketing strategy so if you're a Thai
family and you're like yo I want to
start a business in America the
government will uh help you subsidize
with the yeah with the loan and a menu
and you can they'll help you branding
and all that so then because they're
like if people get hooked on Thai food
they're going to want to visit Thailand
oh okay
that's interesting yeah you know what
like not to speak for the ocean people
like um but I understand comparing it is
saying that it's a [__] version of it
acceptable that's [__] up man
but it was so it was so clearly a
character-based joke that like I get it
but I'm also not loud like if he said if
you replace that with Filipino like I
mean still I'm not like from the
Philippines technically so I I still
can't be I think it's because they don't
got representation so then that's
there's like something I think it's a
down punch still like in in that form
right it's like imagine if you're Kazakh
and then like Borat is the only way
people know what Kazakhstan is which is
why they're upset about it but but the
whole borating in Kazakhstan joke for
the people that do understand the humor
is that he's he's creating a Kazakhstan
that Americans think is Kazakhstan
because Americans are idiots he's making
fun of Americans ignorance he's looking
for the world view of like Kazakhstan at
the end of the day still don't like it
that much right so it's kind of like
yeah yeah they're still there's they
still pay for the joke that's true I
think that's where yeah satire is
difficult I think the representation
thing is a huge point right it's like if
we send if he's like talking [__] on
like Chinese food like how many people
are really going to get mad there's so
many [__] Chinese everything
everywhere but then the second like a
country that doesn't have as much like
familiar when we're sitting here like
what is lost food you know what I mean
it already doesn't have a representation
this becomes like a popularized
representation
you know he's so like definitely I'm
convinced he's uncancelable man that
dude he told us a line hardcore every
time I mean even when he was here
remember he did the joke about like
let's get the world pedal pedals of the
world and then Greta Thunder together to
discuss
but then that's his thing like so he
ended up saying like guys like Asian
people talk [__] about other Asians so
much yeah that's the basis for the
character of Uncle Roger is that he's
gonna [__] on other Asians and that part
you gotta admit which is why it's still
at the end it's it's kind of funny but
the punch down is that one of other
black people exactly yeah but the punch
down is that we don't tend to make fun
of the oceans because it's not enough
that's a deep cut you know what I mean
there's a deep cut we don't really make
fun of that honestly because it's but
also too like do you think because it's
kind of an inside deep joke there is a
population of people that listens to
that and be like oh that's [__]
that's the problem because I don't think
people know enough about it to have a
Counterpoint they're just like oh what
do you know about lotions I heard it's a
[__] version of Thailand you know what I
mean that might be the only thing they
ever heard yeah
that's what's funny about it I just
don't understand taking a character
seriously yeah exactly it's a [__]
character some people don't believe it's
a character sometimes yeah but I can
understand that if no one's ever watched
this show before and they saw this guy
then I can see like that just means that
Uncle Roger is very convinced but you've
hung out with him like when he's not
Uncle Roger he's worse
now but when you watch Uncle Roger too
the first time I saw his videos I just
thought he was kind of clean a lot of
the times and then the more you watch
his stuff you're like oh he's kind of
pretty raunchy like he is he's actually
a lot more uh I don't say offensive but
like yeah he he talks a lot more [__]
than you would especially on stage yeah
he's dark he's he's very dark yeah like
it's crazy yeah I mean if this guy
pissed off the actual like Chinese
government to where they banned his
videos on their platforms and he's still
okay and he's still doubling down on
that too isn't he I think he's not
afraid of any other country honestly
that would be the one that you don't
want to piss off right John Cena bro is
submitting you know when people get mad
it actually does the opposite yeah and
he gets more publicity he does yeah
because he's not really saying anything
that's cancelable like enough
and he's not doing anything that's
justifies being canceled yeah but he's
toning the line to the point where he's
telling the line and he's saying he's
gonna get canceled in the joke right
yeah exactly he says like oh what I said
is [__] up in a different way without
saying what he said was [__] up you
know so I don't really know if it's
doing what the people that don't like
them I think he's gonna be fine and I
think like he that's what he wants man
that reaction and honestly like he does
give a good point where like people do
honestly like Asians to talk a lot of
[__] about it he's not being a true
Asian Uncle if he's not talking [__]
about all other Asian countries and
everybody gets it yeah he does it to
everybody and if it makes any loudest
and people feel better I've never
Googled about Lao Shin food until today
yeah so now we know thanks to Uncle
Roger to learn yeah who's good man
Colleen thinks he's absolutely right
though that's what she said earlier
[Music]